قوانين الامن الداخليه والتامر في عرقله
العداله هذه هي الاتهامات قدمت قدمت من
مجموعه من هيئه المحلفين
والجميع باتا يتفهم النطاق وشده تلك
الجرائم
الناس
والرجالا ونساء في الولايات المتحده وفي
قوات الامن قد كرسوا حياتهم من اجل حمايه
الشعب وحمايه هذه القوانين التي بدورها
تحمي حمص اهميه المعلومات الامنيه
المرتبطه بالولايات المتحده وهذه القوانين
لابد من انفاذها انتهاكات هذه القانون
التي تمس البلاد سوف تكون عرضه للعقوبه
الالتزام بسياده القانون والقوانين
المدنيه تشكل حجر الاساس في بلادنا وان
التزامنا يضرب به مثلا في كافه انحاء
العالم لاننا قد رسمنا هذه القوانين التي
سوف تطبق على الجميع
وهذه القوانين وجمع الاحداث وجمع البيانات
هي التي سوف تحدد مسار هذا التحقيق لا شيء
اكثر من ذلك
ان مجموعه نائبين النواب العامين في
مكتبهم من اصحاب الخبره الواسعه وقد قاموا
بالنظر في هذه القضيه في وفقا لاعلى
المستويات ومستمرون في عمل ذلك مع استمرار
هذه القضيه ومن الضروره ان اشير ان المدع
عليه يجب ان عليه ان يدعي بقرينه البراءه
الى حين ثبات العكس
والى حين ان تقدر المساله الى محكمه
قانونيه وفي هذا الخصوص فان مكتبي سوف
يعمل على تامين حقوقي مصالح كافه الاطراف
ونتطلع لتقديم قضيتنا الى هيئه المحلفين
في محكمه فلوريدا
في الختام اود ان اشكر
العاملين التي فيه قطاعي
القضاء الذين
عملوا دون كلل وملل من اجل الضمان استثباد
القانون وانني فخور للعمل معهم يدا بيد
شكرا جزيلا
لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب
الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس
التنبيهات